we are live okay welcome to another
movement update today we're with jen
whose word is fantasy and building a
movement and business around her one
word fantasy I'm wearing my my one word
shirt today I was just wondered about
that that's really cool i love it yeah
yeah it says one word on the one we're
below ok cool yeah that's our official
logo for I love it good so how are
things going it's been a little while I
know I know it's been a couple months um
it's going good I um I my twitter has
been doing really really well uh if i'm
a broke past six hundred yeah i love
allah I'm I mean you're you up your
Twitter game it's great good good I'm
glad you liked it and I have to admit
I've been a little bit lacking a little
bit in youtube I it's funny because I've
been trying some suggestions you made
slowly but surely um and I think I just
got kind of freaked out about you know
like getting all of them you know all at
once and um so it kind of freaked me out
a little bit but i think i'm back on
track i'm excited i have kind of a plan
to plan it out better and have it
organized so i can make sure and do it
more consistently cuz obviously twitter
is the one thing I I'm doing
consistently and it's the you know it's
the one that's doing the best so where
you put your effort you're gonna suck
getting results yep so what's happening
with YouTube what's the new plan well
the new plan is really just more to UM
to have like plan it out cuz anyway I
was doing before was I was just like
every day I was trying to think of okay
what am I knew today to bring myself
pleasure with my hands and how am I
gonna type it into my book and sometimes
what I would do is I would like wait you
know i would kind of wait to see the
process like the whole idea was you know
I hope you'll get inspired by doing it
um and sometimes I would have sort of an
idea ahead of time of how it might
relate to my book and so instead of just
sort of winging it I'm i have a plan of
you know things that i'm gonna do you
know at least at least five ideas a week
so i can make sure i can kind of do it
more consistently because i really do
want to go back to I really liked when i
was doing it every day it felt really
good and I like that I was overthinking
it i think that was part of my problem
as i was kind of over thinking it there
for a while you know i mean what i would
love to see is combining your your
thoughts around fantasy what it means to
you cuz I'll be sharing one thing on
YouTube you're doing something else
facebook facebook and twitter are kind
of similar to what you're doing right
very similar stuff on both yeah see so
YouTube right now is all about the book
right twitter is all about sharing your
opinions and quotes uh-huh and I'd like
to I like those two pillars I love the
book I love that I love the quotes i
love your powerful opinions right so
what I want copywriting to be in there
too yeah yeah your business right it's
not it doesn't have to be big fantasy is
a part of your business is what you do
and I don't want you just to do
marketing promotional videos but wait
like the idea of this is also to build
up your business and help you get more
clients and way yeah I feel like we've
kind of gone right wait and that's okay
like experimenting is cool and it's
great yeah and now that you've like try
different things it's bringing them
together and so the the that's where
like a book update can be less uh the
book is very personal it's a very ready
for you right yeah yeah wait the tag
along to what you're doing and to
success if you're having and and when
you can inject the lesson for other
people that's great too yeah right
videos work really well when you also
have other stuff yeah implemented right
because people who are going to follow
it now we're just going to be your
friends and some people who get curious
right but if you built up like if you
took the powerful quotes and you
injected you're also your own powerful
opinions and you ducted fantasy
copywriting and those are all regular
videos then your personal
one's become more it gets them it's a
bigger following it gets more
interesting right since you're saying
almost more special in a way yeah and
then it makes your other videos more
powerful because this is your personal
one right on my youtube channel i always
recommend having eighty percent uh kind
of business related in twenty percent
personal not even related to what you're
selling at all okay on my channel will
have I give away some hockey cards
recently and ahead Nina and I were kind
of discussing who to give it to and ok
can I have my son on a video Nina might
make a healthy smoothie in the video
it's like right how does this relate to
believe and what you're doing but it by
showing my personal life it makes the
other videos more special huh no me and
connect with the Moores they're more
willing to they want to watch more they
become more law it's like the voyeur
into what's happened right right they
have a connection with you yeah right
but if all I was posting was my son and
me giving away hot right then it's like
who cares right alright so yeah so I'd
love to see you mix it up okay I love
the sea you had some great videos before
view helping clients right you were I
was helping ideas for writing copy yeah
either an idea for a client or an idea
for a brand you were looking at um true
true and company oh yeah there's how we
do chewing companies content their car
yeah uh and then you had examples of
people who've actually helped you had
the woman I don't know if use a culture
yeah she was a coach oh so bold of her
name is kiana yeah so you helped her and
you show what her web so I got that's
great too but i'm only posting that
makes it right okay hey combine them and
they don't want to be all long and all
that flushed out i know that can be like
you can look guys the odd it's gonna
take me two hours to put all it together
or more right how did you get past read
it but that stress can make it
overwhelming right it makes the movie
more likely to procrastinate
i will say that was one good thing about
me doing the the videos on my book it's
sort of doing in spontaneously because
it kind of got me used to just doing it
on the fly not having to overthink it a
little bit um so if I can apply that to
the copywriting ones I think that would
be helpful with anything you'll get
better at it yeah like so i'm using I'm
Iranian show I have a radio show this
morning okay before when I first started
the radio show it would stress me out
like the whole day before was dedicated
to the preparing for the radio show
thinking of my topics and even the week
before was starting to think about my
topics is this huge deal right I totally
get it and yesterday said oh my radio
shows tomorrow like I need a topic okay
here's my thing and and I just I just
gave myself bullet points took me five
minutes and then I went on today and did
the radio show it's like you get better
at it yeah home so that will happen
right your your book one's got better
your first ones you thought more about
it and uh huh humbled more and ends like
I'm in front of a train who cares right
like you get to get better at it so just
all of them will get better the
copyright ones will get better
everything will get better but the goal
here is I want you to also build a
successful business and not people
following you for no reason like you
wanna get some clients and help you
build this thing up right so showcasing
what you're good at and how you can help
people without it being promotional
you're still having huge value that ties
into explaining how fantasy applies to
businesses I think it'd be I think that
mix works well how I know you know this
isn't you know you know full time to
dedicate the YouTube that's that's fine
right right right uh you know I haven't
seen a blog post come out in the wild it
was like overwhelmed lots of stuff and a
lot of these things work together right
whatever you pull out from a Twitter you
know those quotes yeah you could collect
them and then once a week put together
cuz you're posting on Twitter every day
yeah yeah pull out those quotes and and
just make a short video
of those seven things together like
registering yeah yeah well so the week
or something you know whatever like
things that that are that you found that
are powerful and meaningful to you you
can you can put them up and you can even
read them over like voiceover as they
show up on the screen right um and like
play with it you little evolve you'll
put it up and you'll look at it you get
new ideas and people might leave some
comments and you know you get some new
ideas but i love this just see that mix
so it's not all book because that became
all booked right again all book and like
crazy all booked like everything right
it was you're right well like I want to
hear about the book but maybe it's not
every day mm-hmm it's when you have
something uh meaningful powerful to say
instead of kind of force yourself okay
what did I do with my hands today that I
can say um right like you actually had a
breakthrough that you can you want to
share and talk about that I'm gonna
learn from right right um okay I love it
I love the idea of mixing in more and
and reminding myself to talk about
healthy annecy applies businesses
because I see it but it's like in my
head every day but obviously not
everyone who's watching or you know
reading my Twitter or whatever right and
they need to see that in your in your
material so you're you're making a video
you explained it right you had your
seven step process I think whatever it
was right yeah okay today I'm going to
look at headlines and we're going to
inject fantasy in the headlines to make
it to help them sell more because
they're selling companies hold bras
right there selling abroad yeah exactly
their copy sorry so right not inject
fantasy so that explanation and then
showing how to do it it's great and if
it takes you too long to do it then
don't make it as doesn't have to be as
edited right it could be you looking at
their website and don't picture their
screen and just tell me your thoughts on
it yeah yeah you can start making stuff
and get
to that habit and then you'll learn how
to get better yourself on camera but
then also you'll figure out you know
what what what what system to use like
right almost like a format kinda yeah
it's still early writing you believe a
couple your first ones are great they're
better than my first ones by a long shot
thank you for sure thank you I mean I
got better cuz i did i do to every day
every day there's two videos coming out
so right right practice I'm thought I
think if you're working on your schedule
I'd love to see that okay yes that's a
great idea and maybe it's those four
things maybe something else I mean we
had booked we had personal opinions we
had powerful quotes and then we had
copywriting examples right and even the
copywriting could be broken down between
I hear people I want to help like chew
and company and hear people I'm actually
helping right or even pull out good
examples I see that a lot to like oh
here's a good example of something that
you know use fantasy and its really
awesome yeah or good like that that
could be and that could be something you
get you get in the habit of making quick
videos on as well what willing with the
UM the book one uh-huh any Twitter chat
today you said you liked the word shock
right yeah that was awesome yeah I
totally wrote that down for a copy
because it's great yeah video right like
I'm in this Twitter chat that haven't
put on and we're talking over the like
crazy and he said shop your customers
and I think that's really important
because XYZ right yeah bring it bring
the business part in to those videos
just as much as the non-business dreamer
you know world can be whatever you want
like that's important too yeah mining
them okay great idea and the other
reason why that I love that so much too
it's just the word itself it's always
good to think about words that really
resonate with people that like really do
like you know smack them in the head
instead of just like another boring word
that they have read before a thousand
times you know so anyway yeah there's
two lessons there it's my point that I
could have used if i did a video
accordion
and to help on the overwhelm um if you
keep it to like three a week yeah yeah
that are that are shorter and maybe you
know not as find out maybe only do one a
month that is like detailed planned out
here's what I'm doing with my client
screenshots and the other ones are just
you in front of the camera talking about
something right right it was definitely
easier for me to do yeah another one
thing I would plan out I let you know
and have a kind of a scrip tonight you
know that I said with the screenshots it
would take it like a week to put it
together kind of sort of so yeah and
that can be so it youtube calls those
like hero they call it hero content okay
that's the one where you're putting a
lot of effort into it you really want it
to be special you're really you know
involving a lot of tying up a lot of
your resources and time and energy to
put together right and YouTube has two
kinds of content that they recommend
everybody does you need the hero content
but you'll see what they call the
hygiene content hygiene right yeah which
is which is what you you do every day
right you want yourself you take care of
yourself every day and that's awesome
got to do that for your channel to you
need hygiene content and that could be
you just in front of the phone recording
yourself and maybe you do three you do
it once a day like once a week you just
about you three and you thought okay I'm
talking about my book and 1 i'm talking
about shocked in the next one and i'm
talking about something else and that
may take you 20 minutes to do the free
videos you know maybe we'll take a
little longer to start but as you get
used to it will take you less and less
it can take you 10 minutes to do three
videos right as you get into that
discipline hmm and then you can pull
quotes from there to do your Twitter and
your facebook all right or you can use
the quotes from your twitter facebook to
bring them into your videos um
while working on like one big thing per
month as your hero content yeah okay I
love it I love it I could come I even
planet out kind of to try it a name for
just like one a week on my book and one
a week you know that's more copywriting
focused and you know so I have that in
mind cuz then it will make me it'll be
easier to plan them when I'm ready to do
it will take less time to ya so in the
planning is great and if you ever find
yourself in the moment feeling excited
about something or upset about something
just take out the phone and record it
yeah you don't use it if you look back
and say oh that wasn't that great one to
get in the discipline but yeah well will
you know if you recorded yourself
thinking shocked while you were shocked
it's gonna feel more legit right yeah
okay I'm gonna talk about shock next
week when I start doing my videos and
yeah bullsháá oh it's like you have to
think back to it to try to put yourself
back there you have to act like it
instead of actually feeling like it yeah
so if you can catch yourself feeling
something mm-hmm remember that's it
that's a trick is remembering I know
right that's like a million i wish i
thought of it earlier take it goodness i
gotta film this thing right now yeah um
then that will definitely help with your
the scheduling and content creation and
not having them be so stressed out about
getting you know yeah well every single
day um overall I mean I love the
progress I've love to see that I love
the diversity that's coming out on your
various channels okay I love the
experimentation like you're trying
different things and you're starting to
see results which is great ah those are
just my two thoughts one have copy
somewhere in there on both like Twitter
Facebook but like the written stuff plus
the video and Jackson copy into it okay
and then mix it up with with the other
pillars to ya what about Facebook I
haven't had much luck of facebook I mean
I had a little bit of spike when I did
when I
wrote article and you know another on
another blog and other than that a few
friends off obviously found it and I've
been trying to do content on there
that's a little bit different than
Twitter like it's similar but it's not
I'm not for the most part not doing the
exact same thing it's a little bit more
usually visual or like putting another
you know blog post on there that's sort
of related to fantasy so I don't know if
you have any thoughts about that like
what kind of success you've had on I mr.
for yourself facebook is definitely more
of a picture economy right though they
want pictures mm-hmm even videos I find
like my videos don't do anywhere near as
well as much as your pictures yeah yeah
the videos I'll only actually release
one per day on my facebook channel okay
where I'm actually releasing two per day
in reality right yeah my channel but
only one goes to facebook okay and it
barely gets traction compared to the
pictures yeah um sharing a link is
typically brutal again compared the
pictures right um so you gotta do
pictures right yeah you have that you
like you could put it on your pink um
yeah you have to standard kind of font
sender background so it's not too
difficult to do it or even maybe your
daughter wants to kind of get get
involved right you can help with that
you know it's actually pretty easy to do
I was wondering about that though too
cuz I it seemed like you were all in the
pink which i think is kind of cool cuz
it's branded but i wonder if i should
mixed up a little bit and kind of like
you have with the footer on yours like a
header and a footer so it's a little bit
more variety visually you know good yeah
i mean some of the quotes the quotes
that are of me or of famous
entrepreneurs we have a standard
template for right lot there's a face on
the side and black and white and then
there's a footer underneath right every
day a new Evan quote and a new famous
entrepreneur quote goes up and that's
the format on top of that though will
find believe and inspirational pictures
yeah you know has believe in it yes what
is in it and something else that I just
find like ah that's it like it makes me
think it makes me feel something yeah
was a very um personal you know Tim
right right right but other people I
track people who feel the same way right
and those ones I don't want to mess them
up right like it's it's their picture
that made me feel something I don't want
to put it on black and right yeah yeah I
know you're saying yes so I'll just take
that picture and put the footer on
underneath okay I'm gonna be sharing
that stuff um you know quotes or
pictures that you found that you really
enjoy then yeah keep it intact and you
can throw on a are you so much footer
underneath right okay some of those have
become videos so if you look at our
famous failures okay uh every day we
post the famous failure as well on the
on the oh wow you've been doing it every
day every day is a famous not video is a
joke on facebook okay um and again it's
the face of the entrepreneur and I it's
it's something about how they thought
about quitting or people told me we're
gonna make it some something that you
know people see as a failure right like
Elvis Presley tried up for a band and
you know the guy said you should go back
to truck driver and you ever gonna make
it at the same something like that will
tell them okay okay okay well we'll
share that and then show of Issus face
and then believe and then the footer um
that's become a video series now once a
week where we post once of those every
day on Facebook and Twitter and then
we'll pull them together once a week we
have seven because it's once a week
mm-hm and then we show those pictures
back to back with a soundtrack and we'll
get used to wanting to see those it's
like their little injection of bullying
video form every week
if you take seven uh let's see pictures
or seven quotes that you come up with
seven powerful opinions or mix like
fantasy week 22 whatever you know you
right right the mix of all your stuff in
one video that could just give you extra
video content and it's not that much
extra work because the work is more in
finding this stuff right leveraging the
platform so that they work together a
little bit more okay does your post and
so much great stuff on Twitter but
that's the only way to find it you
haven't turned you down into video and
yeah I barely even put it on Facebook
either and I could yeah hmm okay i love
it i forgot about your famous failures
you do a video too so that's really cool
yeah so it I and it it's a daily post
and then I gets turned into a weekly
video and that's one less video of me
having to be in front of camera and
saying here's a new video I got to get
ready for right this way huh cuz the to
edit those pictures together and just
put down behind it it's a lot easier
than to get in front of the camera and
start talking about something and it
slimy to it's not just all Evan all the
time right it's not just my face each
time it's of their other stores and
other things that I'm sharing and you're
like you're sharing great quotes if I
write back to you a lot on Twitter's
that yes like yeah yeah yeah Wow cuz I'm
looking forward now to my gen like
little right the morning when I go to
Twitter so it's good yeah well that's
cool too also hear that you are just
pulling out quotes because I have
noticed that you pull out course it
obviously just resonate with you not
necessarily all about the leave you know
and then you seem to still go with your
overall message though so um I try and
do that too but I kind of tend to do it
more around like writing and words and
that kind of thing besides fantasy so
look he's like the other day I came here
now what it was but I came across some
quote i was thinking i love this but it
doesn't really relate to my business but
it kind of obviously does cuz it
resonates with me exactly it residences
fantasy because it resonates with you
right not all you were posting then you
detector really niche
audience that's why you're also posting
the other stuff the quotes the
copywriting the personal stuff about you
in the book the powerful opinions on
something all of those together build
something really powerful where if you
only do one angle you're kind of really
limiting yourself right I agree okay
cool I love it all right I'm writing it
down integrated awesome integrated video
plan and social media or forward yes I
think you've made me some programs and
exploration and now it's time to bring
it all together thank you thank you very
much thank you yeah i love the journey
has been fun it's fun to try new things
too and see what works and what
resonates so that's cool cool all right
well um looking forward to the next
video that comes out for everybody
watching Jen where can people find you
on social they can find me at this as
much on Twitter and my facebook is much
ink watching on YouTube I know I'm
starting to did you hear that I'm
starting to lose uh I think my internets
going bad or something no we heard you
what's the YouTube cuz you're frozen um
oh ok I think we're losing you alright
that's okay yeah building your cell
frozen we'll talk to you soon have a
great month thank you everybody if
you're watching you have a question for
Jen you want to support her leave a
comment below thank you guys believe
Thank You Evan thank you